vite au chômage voilà il manquait des
points pour les assedic
blake a pas tout simplement j'ai lu à
peu près à la sans prétention aucune 18
pièces en deux ans et il se trouve que
cela cela faisait partie des trois
préférés et le timing permettait j'avais
du temps pour l'assumer
c'est la première fois que je joue un
rôle de faux culs menteur mauvaise foi
j'ai joué beaucoup de choses notamment
quel inconnu entre autres mais justement
mon frère et ma fille me l'ont dit les
pas tout mon temps me dit voir là dedans
je t'ai jamais vu là dedans
effectivement c'est un registre que je
n'ai que j'ai rarement assumer et ça me
plait pas mal
[Musique]
sa formidable d'ailleurs c'est une des
raisons qui passait ce qui m'a
énormément plu dans la pièce de marc
faye et cie que c'était extrêmement
actuel ça nous concerne et pour le coup
je me sens très très bien qu'on la joue
maintenant
ils ont réagi à des endroits où on
n'avait pas l'habitude on n'a pas encore
l'habitude mais étonnamment ils ont ri à
des moments très inattendu pour nous en
fait moi j'ai un budget fait je paye des
gens courir a des moments mais que pour
moi et il a bien fait hier soir j'avais
beaucoup d'argent et quand enfin tirant
tous les deux sur scène
moi j'entends coulisses qu'il ya une
envie de une écoute et puis le thème de
la pièce je pense qu'ils le connaissent
alors on va se passer quelque chose
effectivement ça monte en puissance
[Musique]
moi j'ai un bouquin qui sort oui chez
laffont est là et foraine s'appelle
l'alphabétisation sous-texte en terme
inconnu
en fait je partis du principe qu on a
inventé des mois des inconnus comme
bouleversifiant mélange il continue avec
un copain journaliste ejb rejoint dans
cette vibration et on a trop on la
refait tout l'alphabet et le principe
c'est d'enlever une lettre ou le rejeter
une lettre vous faites instagram un
instagram tous les deux ou surveiller
tout ça oui je suis professeur de bien
sûr